see signs at malls and hotel casinos
take
lock high but now that message is for
you tonight at home as thieves continue
to target neighborhoods
looking for any unlocked cars and
valuable items in plain sight
metro police recently pushed out the
warning on facebook after seeing posts
and videos surrounding theft madison
kimbrough joining us live with some
really important advice
you need to take care of in a few
minutes here's madison right now
yes okay so first things first you want
to secure
and take your garage remote that you
have here also your insurance card or
your registration
get that out of the car too now if a
thief has those items they have your
personal
info which makes it super easy for them
to make their way into your home
now also don't leave spare keys in the
car the best place to leave a spare key
is at your house
believe it or not even your gym bag is
tempting to a thief
as they may think something else is in
it an obvious given is to not leave any
valuables like
you know your wallet your purse
something several car owners may not
think about
are those push-to-start vehicles where
an actual key is not needed to start the
engine
a lot of the time just because you have
your push-to-start key with you
doesn't mean you automatically lock your
car you need to hit that lock button
once you leave
and also for those that have tinted
windows a lot of people in vegas have
tinted windows
don't think you are immune to getting
burglarized a thief can easily see
inside
with a flashlight now while thieves may
be looking for valuables they also look
for things that are
you would probably think are pretty
random like your back
third row seats certain back road third
road seats in suvs are really easy to
remove
others like catalytic converters those
are big too which in turn
are sold for metal so those are two
things to also look out for
as you can see the rain is coming down
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now
yeah madison thanks for that just